I found a couple girlfriends of mine who
had also been through divorce and things
like that they're like Transcendental
Meditation is like saved my life I did
that you know I tell me more about that
I'd love to get more it's amazing and
I'm a tried meditation and I owe it you
know I mean I'm sure when most people
try it you know your brain is like all
over and you know but it feels like they
do it right everybody's like I don't
know if I'm doing it right well there's
no real if it there's no right or yeah
but I think the idea behind meditation
is to shut your brain off and like stop
thinking that you know but which is
practically impossible because if you
say stop thinking it's all you do if
like don't think if the pink elephant
I'm thinking I'm not thinking yeah
exactly so the thing about
Transcendental Meditation that resonated
with me so much is that you know if you
go through this like training they
really talked you about it and the thing
about it is the way they explained it to
me and being such a visual person that
it really resonated I remember them
showing me a picture of like a brain
that is in fight-or-flight mode which is
basically as humans we operate with
colours like yeah like colour yeah we we
operate from the frontal cortex of our
brain okay and that's that's the CEO of
our brain so that's where we make good
decisions or we like weigh things out
and like done that's the good part when
you're in fight flight or fight flight
or fight mode which is like if a bear is
chasing you sure all that blood like
rushes and you don't and you're just
making a decision based on like [ __ ]
like I'm in trouble I gotta make a
decision and they showed me a picture of
like a brain in that fight-or-flight
mode which is like there's no blood or
very little blood flow coming here and
it's all back there so you're all at
your brain your brain and your chemicals
are all out of whack and so if it and
don't quote me on that that's how I
interpreted it so I might be watching
and be like that's not exactly what it
is so whatever that we're no doctors
here no no no claiming here but that's
how I interpreted it and and basically
what the trends in Dental meditation
does is like it transcends you and helps
your brain truly like calm down and it
transcends you which I know sounds like
weird and trippy but their first time I
did it and then I started doing it what
they give you a mantra that
like very specific to you and can't tell
anybody it and it's just yours and you
repeat the mantra over and over it's not
words though right it's a sound it's
like oh like something like that or it
is sound but it's not words okay but
some somewhere it okay okay and so you
repeat this over and over again and good
to see someone special for them you have
to go to get trained on it okay yeah
like it's a place in LA called the David
Lynch foundation okay where that's where
I went I think you could hire like a
private person to do it to you but you
you have to go it's like about four
hours so you go for I went five week
Monday when did you say Wednesday four
hours straight I'm like cuttin AK in
there I don't know it's like four hours
and you go Monday through Thursday which
is like I was like I do it I'd like
you're like I'll have this done in four
hours
yes I will a so when you're meditating
you it is this bizarre thing and as
someone who not has never really
meditated I I was like I again I was
like I will do anything to feel better
you know and I didn't want to go on
antidepressants just for me like I'm for
you very sensitive to that stuff which
by the way we're talking about
medicating a lot yeah I did not want to
do that so I with the meditation it
it's literally like the best way you can
scrub it is it like something transcends
in you and it's almost like it's almost
like you go to sleep but you don't but
you're it's like you come out of it you
do it for 20 minutes twice a day and you
come you come out of it which I've like
slacked on a little bit lately but you
come out of it and you're like I was I
know I wasn't asleep but I wasn't awake
okay where the [ __ ] was I started a to
stay yeah yeah it is weird even that I
love oh when you come out and and they
say it's a there's an accumulative
effect and which I which is also like
hard to wrap my head around but I you
know the more at you the more you do it
and I'll tell you even my kids won't
notice I mean kids like you don't get as
mad as you used to get there is a
calmness about know I need to try that
then you 100% [ __ ] I think everybody on
the planet should do it there's such a
calmness about me that I've never had
like I've always had like road rage
do you have repairs No
I always like by the way I just got not
to like name drop cars but I just got a
Porsche for the first time nice and I'm
like I just want to drive it so fast car
or the SUV it's the Cayenne nice and and
I realized I because I went somewhere to
test-drive and recommend some roads to
take I know well they told me they have
this like track that you can like
somewhere that you can just search I was
like I want to do that so magic Decker
Canyon Road right here and that'll get
to there too and because I'm a bit of an
aggressive driver which I feel like you
would appreciate definitely gonna say
why are you driving so slow and but you
know there's just like a um just like
intensity about me which I think I still
have but that the the TM has really like
calmed me down
so I think it was like a reset it is a
bit of a reason and when you're doing it
all the time there I can just feel it I
am different than I used to be and
there's a there's a calmness about me
and there's a peace with me that I do
use to have well you said cumulative and
it makes me think of cumulative on the
other side of things which is where
things build up things build up things
build up things build up and so you know
I think of it like it's almost easier to
me associate like if you can just get
back to neutral or like reset back at
zero again even if you accumulate
through the day which you're going to
you're never going to get to where you'd
be if you never did it at all which is
like continuously writing and getting
edgy and you never just and yeah and
that's worrying you release it in ways
that are really unfair right right
you're snapping at people and things and
you know one of the things they remember
them saying about the transcendental
chew is that like if you really do it
regularly you really can purge deep like
you can get stuff that's been like built
up and you ever felt that before I I
mean I've just if I think the like I
said like I just feel like there's I'm
just I've changed so much you know it's
really helped me like just calm down and
help me like deal with things better and
not get I don't I just don't think I get
like as mad I don't think I'm like a lot
of anger and I in his first hardest
things got with my ex-husband even like
when he did things that I think normally
I would have like really freaked out
about haven't I just like I don't really
get angry I mean if you don't have to go
through the purge process then good for
you but I mean I've
my life had that where like it does feel
like a purge or like I was just talking
about with my friend it feels it's like
convulsions almost well I feel like I
purged like cry like well no I did that
a lovely I I feel like I've I feel like
I cried for a year you know I feel like
I cried I have cried so much and I
remember like my therapist being like
and everybody's saying I'm sure you
heard this like yeah the only way
through it the only you know how is the
other side through I'm like yeah only
way to the other side is through and so
I was like I don't want to go through I
want to go around I said yeah I said I
just want to go to sleep and wake up in
three months I want to do yeah and but I
remember everything I read there's a
great book untethered soul no no it's a
good book it's really good I mean I read
a lot during the time and because so
much of what I was being told by like
all these like kind of like spiritual
leaders and people I was like meeting
and talking to you it was like you have
to go through it you have to feel it and
of course my response to that was like I
don't want to feel it it feels horrible
or you have to I remember them saying to
me - you have to surrender to it and I
was I was Wonder - it man I remember
I'll stand up - yeah yeah you just want
to fight it you're you doing real
bastard yeah well bastard yeah and I
remember being like I give up like I I
just I remember there was and there it
was and and I think I just and it's
almost it's such a like that feeling is
is now a little bit of a distant memory
and remember it but fades quick quick
and but I remember feeling like I wanted
to die I was just gonna say I remember
when I was going through it I was
retiring mm-hmm breaking up with my
boyfriend of five years and moving all
within days yeah and I knew it was
coming
yeah and I seriously felt like I wanted
like I was dying yeah that's how I felt
too
[Music]
you